mehr Fortschritt Wagen das hatte sich
die Ampelkoalition nach der
Bundestagswahl vor gut einem Jahr
vorgenommen jetzt müssen SPD Grüne und
FDP vor allem mehr Krise meistern und
dafür alte Grundsätze über Bord werfen
Friedens Energie und Finanzpolitik
werden neu vermessen am Sonntag wird in
Niedersachsen gewählt kleiner Prüfstein
auch für Scholz Harbeck und Lindner und
für den Kurs des Oppositionsführers März
Regieren in der Krise wie stark ist die
Ampel unser Thema in der phoenix-runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin das sind meine Gäste bei uns ist
Professor Thorsten Faas erst
Politikwissenschaftler an der Freien
Universität Berlin und ich begrüße
Dorothea Siems chefkorrespondentin für
Wirtschaftspolitik der Tageszeitung Die
Welt herzlich Willkommen an Hänig sie
ist Redaktionsleiterin bei der Zeit im
Osten und Leiterin des Leipziger
korrespondentenbüros derzeit und
herzlich willkommen Marc Felix rau von
der neuen Züricher Zeitung Leiter des
Berliner Büros und auch Chefredakteur
der NZZ in Deutschland und der sera mit
ihnen möchte ich gerne beginnen man
sieht ja es ist große Krise auf allen
Ebenen was macht die Ampel richtig gut
gerade
das macht sie richtig gut
sie macht richtig gute gigantische
Ankündigungen mit großen Begriffen von
Zeiten Wänden bis zu Doppel wumsen
sie macht richtig gut
Schuldenaufnahme ich glaube so
gigantische Kreditprogramme gab es noch
nicht in der Summe sind das glaube ich
neben dem regulären Haushalt
mittlerweile 500 Milliarden der
Abwehrschirm das sogenannte
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr was ja
sonderschulden sind und die
nachtragshaushalte also das macht sie
richtig gut ob das alles richtig gut
funktioniert werden wir sehen ich glaube
im Winter kommt die große Probe
wie sehen sie sehen sie
würden sie ein serrade widersprechen
wollen also gibt es Dinge die wirklich
gut laufen die Frage ist ob wir in
Zeiten leben wo wirklich Dinge richtig
gut laufen können ich finde das darf man
ja nicht ganz vergessen in welchen
Zeiten wir leben die zeitenwände ist ja
eben nicht nur ein Symbol Begriff von
der Stelle sondern hat er doch sehr
traurige aber reale Gründe warum wir
davon sprechen und dann kann sie schon
fragen ich meine es ist eine neue
Regierung die ist ein Jahr im Amt das
sind neue Akteure sie raufen sich immer
wieder zusammen sie bringen Dinge auf
den Weg in einen wirklich schwierigen
Bündnis insofern machen Sie es richtig
gut weiß man nicht ob es irgendjemand
richtig gut machen könnte aber ich
glaube Endzeitstimmung wäre jetzt auch
nicht angesagt Frau herrlich es gibt den
dieses Versprechen des Bundeskanzlers
you'll never walk alone also du gehst
nicht alleine wir sind bei dir sozusagen
als Regierung kommt das Versprechen an
besonders im Osten
Osten hat die ältere Bevölkerung
jedenfalls noch kein Englisch gelernt
ich weiß gar nicht ob es da verstanden
wird aber Spaß beiseite
ja das klingt gut natürlich wird man
sich von der Regierung wünschen dass sie
an der eigenen Seite steht das ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit die er
ausgesprochen hat und die Ängste sind
hier glaube ich also in Ostdeutschland
am größten einfach weil der Wohlstand am
geringsten ist und dann ist ja logisch
dass man relativ schnell Angst vor dem
sozialen Abstieg hat wenn man sozial
ohnehin nicht besonders weit oben steht
das heißt dafür steht die Ampelkoalition
im Moment nicht diesen sozialen Abstieg
zu verhindern es ist in jedem Fall noch
nicht so richtig viel Vertrauen da dass
diese großen Ankündigungen die ja schon
erwähnt worden sind
dass die wirklich Linderung bringen
Frau Siems wie sehen sie es wenn man
dann sagt die Menschen im Osten
vertrauen dem nicht dass all die großen
gigantischen Schulden die jetzt sehr rau
erwähnt hat dass sie wirklich ankommen
wie sieht's aus bei den Unternehmen in
diesem Lande also wie groß sind die
Sorgen und wie viel Vertrauen hat man da
die Ampelkoalition also in der
Wirtschaft hat man direkt nach dem
Antritt dieser Bundesregierung durchaus
Hoffnung gehabt weil es klang manches
recht vielversprechend trotz
der Tatsache dass man das klar war dass
es eben mal Energiewende schneller gehen
soll was für manche eben schwierig wird
aber eben eigentlich doch in Richtung
Zukunft
jetzt spürt man da vielfach nackte Panik
weil wir sind jetzt mehr als sieben
Monate nach dem Beginn dieses russischen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine und
wir haben zwei
entlastungspakete schon gehabt
dann haben wir einen Wirtschaft das
Hilfsprogramm was eigentlich sehr stark
auf große Industrieunternehmen
zugeschnitten ist wo eben gesagt wird
also wenn die Energiekosten extrem hoch
sind denn können sie Zuschüsse
beantragen das ist aber sehr
bürokratisch sehr schwierig der
Mittelstand ist eigentlich völlig allein
gelassen muss ich dann anhören von einem
Wirtschaftsminister dass es eben sein
kann dass man im Winter nicht produziert
aber nicht insolvent geht inzwischen
gehen etliche insolvent viele
sehen eben auch gar nicht dass die
Programme auf Sie zugeschnitten sind die
hoffen jetzt dringend dass bei dem
dritten Paket endlich was für sie auch
drin ist dass das Ihnen hilft soll ja
passieren aber wir wissen nicht wie also
es ist vom Gaspreis und Deckel die Rede
und das ist für viele schon
wir sehen dass das Produktion
runtergeschraubt werden gerade da wo es
energieintensiv ist wir also
beispielsweise Chemieindustrie hat zehn
Prozent weniger das sind gerade der
Mittelstand der da einfach nicht mehr
kann und dann eben aufhört zu
produzieren tatsächlich und wenn er das
länger macht dann ist er einfach tot und
deswegen also in der Industrie ist es
tatsächlich lange nach 12 und das ist
auch glaube ich eben mit unter Umständen
in vielen Bereichen nicht mehr
aufzufangen jetzt kann man ja sagen so
wie Thorsten Faß argumentiert hat es
sind nun mal wahnsinnig schwierige
Zeiten und das aber ich weiß nicht wer
sich vielleicht noch erinnert wie das in
der Finanzkrise war da ist ja in einem
Jahr die Wirtschaft mal auf fünf Prozent
geschrumpft sowas hatte es in der
Nachkriegsdeutschland nie gegeben und da
hatten wir ein beispielsweise ein
Bankenrettungsfonds aufgelegt innerhalb
von einer Woche war der durch sämtliche
parlamentarischen Stufen das sind
natürlich es gab einen ein Bekenntnis
der Bundesregierung damals das war
Angela Merkel mit Peer Steinbrück die
sich hingestellt haben eine Zusicherung
gegeben haben dass alle Bankguthaben
sicher sind damals gab es Panik ja dass
das genau vielleicht nicht der Fall ist
und das war einfach der der das
Auftreten an dieser Situation kein
Streit sondern zu sagen die haben sich
vorher viel gestritten also mehr
Vertrauen eine konsistente Kommunikation
und dann schafft so was Vertrauen ich
finde wir sehen zurzeit sehr viel
handwerkliche Fehler sehr viel Streit
und dann eben Dinge wie bei der
wieder bei der gastumlage das
preisumlage die dann einfach wieder
gekippt wird ganz im letzten Augenblick
bei dem Punkt wenn also Kommunikation
auch eine Serie wenn man sowas wie
Doppel Wumms ist das einfach schlechte
Kommunikation ist oder ist es ein cooler
Begriff mit dem man dann was anfangen
kann wie beurteilen Sie das
weiß ich cool würde ich ihn jetzt nicht
ich finde es auch nicht schlimm wenn
wenn man mal irgendwie meins und Begriff
prägen zu müssen mich erinnert dass an
diese alte batman-serie aus den 60ern
ich weiß nicht wer sich erinnert mit
Adam West wenn er dann Schurken verhauen
hat dann gab es immer so riesige
wortblasen Puff Bang Doppelpunkt daran
erinnert mich das so ein bisschen nein
aber im Ernst die Kommunikation ist ist
natürlich schwierig wenn man alles
mögliche verspricht und und dann
tatsächlich handwerklich irgendwie ganz
hektisch Dinge wieder abwickeln muss wie
die Gasanlage zwei Tage bevor das ganze
starten sollte das ist tatsächlich
verheerend weil gerade also nicht nur
Privathaushalt aber gerade Unternehmen
müssen ja planen und die können im
Moment nicht planen jetzt wollen wir mal
schauen was bei der gaspreisbremse
voraussichtlicher nächste Woche
vorgestellt wird die Vorsitzender der
Kommission Veronika Grimm ist ja eine
wirklich renommierte
Ökonomen die auch in der Wirtschaft
angesehen ist mal schauen ob sie sich
gegen die anderen in der Kommission
durchsetzen kann mit einem vernünftigen
Vorschlag damit tatsächlich am Ende bei
diesem Projekt auch die Preissignale
ankommen nach wie vor weil wir haben ja
das Problem ersetzt weniger die
Kommunikation als die handwerklichen
Fehler die gemacht werden die
Kommunikation ist als wir hier im Mai
zusammen saßen habe ich gesagt dass der
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck ganz
hervorragend kommuniziert ganz anders
als der Kanzler daran würde ich nach wie
vor festhalten das Problem ist nur
Kommunikation ist nicht alles er ist ja
nicht der Sprecher des
Wirtschaftsministers ist der
Wirtschaftsminister das heißt das
politische Handwerk muss dann schon auch
Stimmen
ich finde auch das Problem am
doppelwumms ist ja überhaupt nicht
dieser Name ist sehr schön wenn sich
Bundeskanzler die wir ja in der letzten
Zeit immer erlebt haben als politische
Figuren die möglichst unverständlich
bleiben wollen oder möglichst so
langweilig sprechen dass niemand mehr
zuhören will ist ja schön wenn
Bundeskanzler eingängige Worte finden
finde ich das Problem am doppelwumms ist
ja dass wir schon drei Wochen zuvor ein
sogenanntes drittes entlastungs nicht
gesehen haben dass 65 Milliarden schwer
war drei Wochen später ein neues
Entlastungspaket das jetzt 200
Milliarden schwer sein soll und es wirkt
so ein bisschen panisch ja es wirkt
nicht überlegt was wir da machen sondern
wir schenken 300 Euro raus für jeden
Rentner und jeden Studenten und vorher
schon an jeden anderen
Angestellten das kann man machen aber
zumindest mir fehlt das Vertrauen dass
die Lösung die da vorgeschlagen wird auf
Augenhöhe ist mit dem Problem dass wir
haben und man kann es nicht machen das
ist doch das Problem also wir hauen Geld
raus also wie sie sagen man gibt da und
man gibt da zufällig wurde das auch im
September also vor der niedersachsenwahl
dass man ihm auch alle Rentner was gibt
und die Studenten vorher sagten sie auch
schon eben den noch größere Gruppe aller
Arbeitnehmer das Geld ist einfach wird
einfach so vergeben an Leute die es
teilweise dringend brauchen die
bräuchten aber mehr und an welche die es
nicht unbedingt bräuchten und das ist
also wir haben eine in die Doppel also
inzwischen zweistellig ist das ist das
und wenn dann der Staat das Geld
raushaut eben nicht zielgenau
sondern eben wir haben schon das war ja
vorhin gesagt welche großen Summen da im
Raum sind dann füttert er die Inflation
weiter unser Geld wird immer weniger
wert und diese Reaktion werden dann
entsprechend werden die immer größer die
Pakete das ist nicht zielführend das ist
immer getrieben um auch diesen
Stimmungen was entgegenzusetzen die sind
dieser zunehmenden Verunsicherung der
Bevölkerung aber es ist überhaupt nicht
zielführend unter den Seiten oder so
oder dieses neun Euro Ticket das ist
verpufft keiner ist
es doch heute sie haben doch heute
nichts davon und es haben mal reiche
Leute mitnehmen können im Tankrabatt
oder armer also es ist überhaupt nicht
zielgenau gewesen und der Koalition dass
sie eine Menge erreicht hat zum Beispiel
das was sie versprochen hat den
Mindestlohn der jetzt zum ersten Oktober
auf 12 Euro steigt
dann die Abschaffung kalte Progression
Erhöhung des Kindergeldes Abschaffung
EEG-Umlage Bürgergeld statt Hartz IV
Herr Phase man das sieht dann ist es ja
eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge was man
dann erreicht hat in einem Jahr ja
sicherlich und ich würde noch mal
betonen ist immer so ein bisschen die
Frage womit vergleicht man das
eigentlich was gerade passiert das ist
ein ungewöhnliches Bündnis das darf man
nicht vergessen das sind nicht drei
Partner die seit Jahren
zusammengearbeitet haben die sind jetzt
ein Jahr im Amt zwei dieser Parteien
sind auch völlig neuen Regierungen waren
viele Jahre nicht in Regierung wenn man
es vergleichen würde mit früheren
Regierungen dann wäre das eigentlich so
Schwarz-Gelb 2010 und wenn man sich weil
damals war die FDP auch neu wenn man
sich deren Wert mal anguckt ein Jahr
nach der Wahl dann steht die Ampel
glänzend da heute weil die FDP war
damals schon am Abgrund die CDU stand
auch sehr sehr schlecht da und man muss
doch auch sehen einfach wenn man mal die
Argumente anhört die jetzt hier schon
gefallen sind sie haben gesagt es wird
viel Geld ausgegeben vielleicht auch
eher symbolisch sie haben gesagt das
kommt zu spät sie haben gesagt Menschen
haben Fake aber irgendwie weiß man noch
nicht so recht wo es ankommt das zeigt
er einfach die Dimension der
Herausforderung auch der
Widersprüchlichkeiten die da bestehen
und wenn man dann sagt doppelbums ist es
eigentlich cool ich meine wer schreibt
denn die ganze Zeit von doppelwurms das
ich meine es funktioniert ja einfach
auch an der Stelle das müsste man dann
vielleicht auch mal animieren wenn man
jetzt wir haben neue Zahlen vom
Deutschland trennt danach liegt die SPD
bei 17 Prozent die CDU bei 28 also
deutlich stärker die Grünen bei 19 die
FDP bei 7 AFD 15 und die Linken bei 5
also das heißt die SPD sieht nicht gut
aus die Kanzlerpartei und ein wichtiger
anderer Wert ist wenn man nach der
Zufriedenheit mit der Ampelkoalition
fragt dann sind 68 Prozent weniger oder
gar nicht zufrieden also Frau Herr nicht
die SPD wird abgestraft und die AFD
gewinnt dafür
das hat glaube ich etwas damit zu tun
oder zunächst einmal die AFD ist ja in
gar keiner so guten Situationen also sie
ist es nicht so dass sie mit besonders
gutem Verhalten in der Opposition
auffallen würde dass sie besonders
markant wäre in ihre politischen Arbeit
gerade sie hat im Januar erst den
Vorsitzenden Jörg Meuthen verloren der
ausgetreten ist viele
Verfassungsschutzämter beobachten sie
jetzt also die Partei ist in einer
strukturell schwierigen Phase und
trotzdem gewinnt sie dazu das hat
jedenfalls meinem Eindruck nach
politische Gründe nämlich dass sie ein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal hat inhaltlich
sie ist die einzige Partei die sich
hinstellt und sagt dieser Krieg ist
schlimm aber wir als Deutsche müssen uns
daraus halten wir können uns das nicht
leisten mit seinem Zonen einzugreifen
bzw die Ukraine mit Waffen zu
unterstützen und das ist eine Position
die
relativ viele Menschen in der
Bevölkerung vertreten so noch mehr
Menschen als AFD wählen bzw sich jetzt
für die AFD ansprechen und deswegen
schafft sie es ohne großes Zutun in den
Umfragen zu steigen da gibt es auch eine
Zahl im vom Deutschlandtrend also 47
Prozent sind für eine Zurückhaltung und
43 Prozent sind eigentlich für Härte und
Entschlossenheit 56 Prozent der
Bevölkerung haben große Sorgen dass
Deutschland in diesem Krieg
hineingezogen sind werden Herr seraub
wie schwer ist es dieses Regieren in
dieser
Kriegszeit
ist das der Hauptpunkt wo man sagt da
kann man eigentlich auch nur Fehler
machen als Regierung
das weiß ich nicht ich glaube am Ende
wird wenn Bilanz gezogen wird gegen Ende
der Legislaturperiode wird das für die
deutschen Wähler vor allem um zwei Dinge
gehen das eine ist haben wir wieder
bezahlbare Energiepreise ich glaube das
wird die für die meisten Menschen so so
zynisch das klingen mag noch wichtiger
sein als wie es in der Ukraine aussieht
und
konnte die Inflation zurückgehen worauf
jetzt die Bundesregierung natürlich nur
sehr beschränkt Einfluss nehmen kann
aber nichtsdestotrotz wird sie
wahrscheinlich dafür in Mithaftung
genommen werden und ich glaube die
Energiepreise sind einfach jetzt das
entscheidende Thema und da wollte ich
noch mal sagen weil wir über
Kommunikation gesprochen haben und
Handwerk
die Regierung hat viel zu spät erkannt
das ist darauf ankommt dass eigene
Energieangebot in Deutschland jetzt hoch
zu fahren und zwar mit allen Mitteln die
zur Verfügung stehen also das der
Vizekanzler wirklich zum Jagen getragen
werden muss bei der Kernkraft das ist
dass er erst sagt wir brauchen das nicht
das ist dann heißt irgendwie okay zwei
der drei meiner die wir noch haben als
stille Reserve und jetzt sozusagen
dürfen zwei wahrscheinlich am Netz
bleiben aber maximal bis April das ist
aus meiner Sicht wirklich
verantwortungslos es gibt es gab schon
im Frühjahr eine Empfehlung der
Internationalen Energieagentur die hat
gesagt unter anderem damit wir uns
unabhängig machen können von Russland
müssen wir jetzt alles was wir am
kernkraftkapazitäten haben hochfahren
müssen beschlossene Schließung
rückgängig machen und wir brauchen ja
die Erneuerbaren allein werden
Deutschland als Industriestandort nicht
erhalten können wir sind noch nicht so
weit in der Technologie auch in der
Speichertechnologie das heißt wir
brauchen eine Brücken
Energiequelle und wenn wir jetzt nicht
Fracking ein großes Ziel in
Niedersachsen betreiben wollen
brauchen wir einen Ausstieg aus dem
Atomausstieg dann werden auch die drei
Meiler nicht reichen sondern da müssen
tatsächlich vermutlich neue
Atomkraftwerke gebaut werden das wäre
doch aber eigentlich nicht denkbar mit
den Grünen
Neubau ist auch was was uns im Moment
jetzt über diese diese mangelnde
Situation noch nicht hinweg hilft ob man
tatsächlich sagt das ist die CO2 Zukunft
dass man eben als Brückentechnologie
auch Atomenergie wieder stärker hat das
wird innerhalb Europas sichern Thema ich
glaube die Deutschen die Fremde mit
dieser mit dieser Energiequelle aber
nichtsdestotrotz für die nächsten zwei
Jahre wahrscheinlich auch für die
nächsten fünf Jahre halte ich das
dringend für nötig übrigens auch die ja
schon erwähnte Wirtschaftsweise Veronika
Grimm hat es auch jetzt die sagt dass
die ganze Zeit
ganz dringend genauso wie Kohle auch bei
Kohle bremst das Wirtschaftsministerium
weil sie auch da Rücksicht nehmen auf
und eben eigentlich mit ideologischen
Stahlkappen rangehen bei Ihnen eine sie
sagen aber man kann die Nachfrageseite
stärker beeinflussen was aber
kurzfristig bedeutet dass man
energieintensive Industrien abschaltet
das kann der Weg nicht sein weil wir das
kostet unglaublich dauerhaft Wohlstand
und ich glaube tatsächlich ich habe
nicht das Problem dass wir jetzt kein
Geld ausgeben sollten weil sie sagten es
kommt zu spät ich glaube wir haben nur
nicht die richtige Prioritätensetzung
ich denke jetzt ist es wichtig erstmal
alles was wir an heimischer Energie noch
machen können ich würde auch das
Tracking nicht ausschließen warum nehmen
wir gefragtes Gas von überall woanders
mit
Mitarbeitern und das sind ungefähr 40
Mal Jahresleistung dessen was wir an
gastlieferungen aus den USA bekommen
haben wir unter unserem Boden also wir
müssen mal über solche Sachen nachdenken
anstatt eben bei uns immer sauber sein
zu wollen aber das im Endeffekt er aus
Nachbarländern teilweise zu kaufen das
ist aber natürlich für die größte
Schritte den sie machen aber ich glaube
trotzdem eine und das wurde für mich
eine gute Krisenpolitik ausmachen wenn
man nicht wie bei dem bei dem
Zusammensetzen als Koalition und dann
den Vertrag Koalitionsvertrag machen
gesagt hat jeder kriegt so seine seinen
Teilen
die einheitlich zusammen versuchen eine
Lösung und dazu gehört dringend diesen
Industriestandort zu erhalten weil sonst
müssen wir über ganz viele Sachen Kim
oder sie wollten da direkt was zusammen
fahren
zum einen weil sie gesagt haben die
Deutschen können sich mit Atomenergie
nicht mehr so gut anfreunden ich glaube
das stimmt nicht die Grünen können sich
damit nicht mehr anfreunden in der
Bevölkerung gibt es eine relativ große
Sympathie für die Idee länger bei dieser
Technologie zu sein aber nicht aber
nicht neue bauen
ist das Strecken bin ich voll dafür und
ich denke fünf Jahre und auch mit neuen
Brennstäben das glaube ich ist dringend
erforderlich Christian Lindner hat
vorgeschlagen dass älter Verteiler die
zwar schon abgeschaltet sind aber noch
funktionieren hochgefahren werden
könnten auch ziemlich spät das wäre
jetzt im Oktober Anfang darüber zu
diskutieren über wurde im Frühjahr
diskutiert
aber ich wollte nur sagen wir haben
nicht jetzt angefangen Scholz hat gesagt
es bringt nichts und Herr Habeck hat im
Frühjahr gesagt wir haben kein
Stromproblem das ist finde ich fatal
gewesen war alle Experten das Gegenteil
gesagt haben und jetzt also man kann
kein in solcher Krise nicht ein halbes
Jahr lang erstmal das kleine einmal eins
des Energiemarktes lernen müssen auf
offener Bühne das finde ich auch keine
gute Kommunikation übrigens von den habe
ich das finde ich schlecht ja
sie haben sich sie haben das Thema
Fracking angesprochen das Fracking Gas
was wir hätten liegt er in Niedersachsen
und wenn man sich den Wahlkampf dort
angeguckt hat dann haben Politiker fast
alle Parteien betontes Fracking dass sie
Fracking nicht wollen und ich glaube das
ist jetzt nicht nur ein
niedersächsisches Problem sondern es ist
auch ein bisschen typisch deutsch dass
wir
die unangenehmen Dinge gern auslagern
wollen wenn sie irgendwo einen Windrad
bauen dann haben sie die halbe
Bevölkerung gegen sich ein Atomkraftwerk
will auch niemand mehr neben sich haben
und Fracking wollen die Niedersachsen
natürlich auch nicht also ich glaube da
stehen wir jetzt auch langsam vor der
Debatte was das Land eigentlich selber
zu leisten bereit ist für den eigenen
Wohlstand das heißt da müsste es auch
eine andere Ansprache geben also habe
Katja relativ am Anfang gesagt wir
werden alle ärmer werden also ist es das
auch was fehlt also eine klarere
Ansprache dass wir uns wirklich ändern
müssen
ich glaube wir können uns die Dimension
des Problems noch nicht vorstellen noch
funktioniert ja alles noch sitzen wir in
geheizten Wohnungen und noch haben wir
nicht allzu viele
Insolvenzen gesehen das wird
wahrscheinlich in einem Jahr ganz anders
sein vielleicht diskutieren wir dann
anders über Fracking in Niedersachsen
ist einfach nicht die Schätzungen sind
ja auch extrem unterschiedlich und
natürlich kann man sagen gerade haben
sich die Werte gedreht aber jahrelang
hat auch der Atomausstieg immense
Zustimmung und Umfragen erfahren es ist
halt einfach eine sehr sehr besondere
Situation und natürlich können wir jetzt
hier sagen die Grünen warme springen die
denn nicht aber zugleich lesen wir auch
immer der muss irgendwie über seinen
Parteitag kommen wo wir ja auch wieder
merken das ist eben für die Grünen so
wie die Schuldenbremse vielleicht für
Christian Lindner das ist nicht
irgendein Thema
auch ermöglichen sonst heißt es doch
wieder worauf können wir uns denn
verlassen überhaupt das ist einfach an
die Lämmern die mir da stecken und wir
sollten jetzt hier heute nicht so tun
als hätten wir mal eben schnell die
Lösungen
ist finde ich schon zu klein gedacht
also ich sprach jetzt nicht von
Landtagswahl beispielsweise sondern von
Parteitag und natürlich ist ein
Parteitag des höchste Gremium für einen
Partei und da können wir doch jetzt
heute Abend hier nicht sitzen weil ja
klar muss der Atomkraft beschließen wie
wie naiv kann er denn sein
also die SPD ihre eigenen
Friedenspolitik die FDP mit der
Schuldenbremse die Grünen mit den
Atomkraftwerken am Anfang dieses dieser
Koalition haben alle die haben neuen
politischen Spiel das wird was ganz
Neues ist davon noch irgendwas übrig von
dieser Idee von von diesem Zauber des
neuen
nein wobei man auch da
bemerkenswerterweise feststellen könnte
dass das irgendwie fachfangen hat damals
denn es war doch auch damals klar
wirtschaftspolitisch das worüber wir
hier heute reden steht die FDP auf der
einen Seite rum Rot und Grün steht auf
der anderen Seite und der der glaube das
könnte man mal eben und man bräuchte
keine Nachtsitzung mehr also das war
doch eigentlich die naive Geschichte und
mehr Fortschritt waren warum weil sie
sich natürlich gesellschaftspolitisch
sehr einig sind lohnt sich ja auch
darauf immer wieder zurückziehen können
da funktionieren sie übrigens auch
durchaus sind nur eben nicht die Themen
gerade aber
sozialwirtschaftspolitik da passen diese
Partner einfach nicht zusammen und das
auf der einen Seite jetzt Verrenkung
gemacht werden dass man sagen wir halten
doch die Schuldenbremse ein von FTP
Seite auf der anderen Seite Verrenkung
gemacht werden dass man sagt aber der
Atomausstieg der gilt auch das zeigt
genau dass Dilemma dass da einfach
Partner zusammen gezwungen werden
vielleicht ist auch ausprobieren wollten
wo aber nicht nur Kommunikation sondern
wo einfach fundamentale Unterschiede
aufeinanderprallt das ist dann in der
Demokratie auch eigentlich gut dass es
die gibt aber nur schwierig ich finde
die Grünen haben aber weil sie gerade
sagten Robert Habeck muss ja über den
Parteitag hinweg und da haben sie total
recht die Grünen haben aber insbesondere
Robert Habeck ein besonderes Problem es
gibt dort nicht das eine Machtzentrum
das da heißt Robert Habeck sondern wir
haben es mit zwei starken Ministern zu
tun die wichtige
Ämter haben wichtige Ministerien das
Außenministerium Anna-Lena baerburg klar
und das Wirtschaftsministerium Robert
Habeck und die beiden bekriegen sich
jetzt nicht auf offener Bühne wie wir es
von der CDU vielleicht kennen aber sie
haben sich überworfen so spätestens seit
dem Bundestagswahlkampf arbeiten sie
nicht mehr so gut zusammen wie man es
vorher von ihnen kannte und der eine
schützt den anderen nicht darauf kommt
es aber an wenn man eine relativ kleine
Partei ist mit noch nicht so große
Traktionen
ganz andersrum auch nicht und wenn man
so ganz allein auf weiter Flur steht
dann hat man es natürlich schwer ist
recht über ein Parteitag hinwegzukommen
mit so etwas ungemütlichem für die
Grünen wir den Atom dann schauen wir
doch mal auf diese Akteure schauen wir
mal auf Scholz Habeck und Lindner heißt
Herr Rau wer macht denn da oder wer ist
Ihrer Meinung nach derjenige den die
Bürger der vielleicht am meisten
zutrauen durch diese Krise zukommen
am Anfang wurde Habeck sie haben ihn ja
selber im Mai haben sie ja selber gesagt
wie gut er das macht der macht im Moment
richtig gut von denen wenn ich noch eine
Anmerkung machen darf zu dem was die
Kollegen gerade gesagt haben das ist mir
dann doch für das Thema des heutigen
Abends nämlich schafft diese Regierung
die Bewältigung dieser Krise ein
bisschen viel
parteipolitische parteipolitisches
Verständnis also Sie haben ja recht man
muss sozusagen aus der binnenlogik der
Grünen heraus den Widerstand gegen die
Kernenergie nachvollziehen und natürlich
dann gibt es irgendwie das Zerwürfnis
zwischen Frau bärburg und Herrn Habeck
ja aber
wenn wir wenn wir so argumentieren dann
können wir sozusagen dann wird es den
großen Wurf überhaupt gar nicht geben
können und ich glaube da müssen
tatsächlich auch diese
Regierungsparteien in einer solchen Lage
wo es tatsächlich darf man nochmal die
Kollegin zitieren darum geht ob
Deutschland als
Industriestandort erhalten bleibt oder
tatsächlich nicht mehr und was danach
käme wollen wir uns wirklich nicht
vorstellen da muss gelten das Land
zuerst und die Partei danach wirklich
jetzt zu der Frage ich würde sagen dass
im Prinzip da alle keine richtig gute
Figur abgeben
über Herrn Scholz haben wir schon
gesprochen Herr Habeck der sich
irgendwie einmal sagt wir haben keinen
Strompreis kein Stromproblem und dann
haben wir es doch der sagt hoch
irgendwie der Gasmarkt ist ja viel
komplizierter als gedacht und gibt viel
mehr Verflechtung also der sozusagen der
ist quasi in der in der Ausbildung zum
Wirtschaftsminister auf offener Bühne
und Herr Lindner ja der jure hat er nach
wie vor sozusagen an der Schuldenbremse
festhalten können de facto haben wir
mittlerweile so viele sonderschulden in
gigantischer Höhe und nachtragshaushalte
das ist eigentlich ein
Etikettenschwindel ist und er trägt auch
da müsste man könnte man doch ehrlicher
sein und sagen man kassiert die
Schuldenbremse ein oder die können wir
eh dann nicht dann ist durchhalten
jein weil wenn sie wenn sie so ein
Abwehrschirm haben dann ist der ja auch
zweckgebunden also sie können da jetzt
nicht irgendwie keine Ahnung
irgendwelche sozialpolitischen
Sonderwünsche der SPD mitfinanzieren
also das ist schon noch mal was anderes
glaube ich als der normale Haushalt
nichtsdestotrotz erlindner das wollte
ich noch sagen hat ja diesen ganzen
Murks diese ganzen Finanz diesen
finanzpolitischen Populismus diese diese
verpuffungseffekte von hier meine 300
Euro Einmalzahlung auch an Rentner die
es nicht brauchen Studenten die es nicht
brauchen hier dieses 9-euro-ticket was
für dich verpufft ist äh der
benzinrabatt das hat er ja alles
mitgetragen so und das ist tatsächlich
für eine liberale Partei
wirklichen Sündenfall da muss man auch
sagen da würde ich sagen ist er über
also über den Tisch gezogen oder war
eben einfach von sich zu überzeugt weil
genau das hätte er wissen müssen dass er
irgendwann das Geld für die Wirtschaft
braucht dass er das irgendwann das Geld
für das untere Drittel braucht das ist
einfach klar das hat jeder immer gesagt
weil wir schön in unserem Land nicht
akzeptieren dass Leute in der Wohnung
frieren oder verhungern das geht einfach
nicht das heißt für die die das absolut
überfordert muskelt da sein und genau
und für die Wirtschaft ist es eine
Überlebensfrage von uns allen was was
unseren Wohlstand angeht insofern war
auch das klar dass eine FDP sich niemals
dagegen stellen kann der Wirtschaft dann
irgendwie was zu geben was vernünftig
ist aber dass er die anderen Sachen alle
mitgemacht hat teilweise auch mit dem
Tankrabatt ja selber angetrieben hat
passiert wenn das nicht gemacht hätte
das
noch mal im Frühjahr war absehbar was
hier auf uns zurollt und das ist das was
ich dieser Bundesregierung vorwerfe sie
hat lange auch schleifen lassen der
Wirtschaft also die Wirtschaftsweisen
eigentlich früher mal ein absolut
wichtiges
Institut die haben etwa die Agenda 2010
damals konzipiert die haben in der
Finanzkrise im Hintergrund gewirkt die
hat man einfach gar nicht gefragt bzw
hat man nicht mal be also man holt sich
gar nicht die Expertise weil die ganzen
Sachen mit denen wir uns jetzt
beschäftigen wie viele dass man eben
beim Energieangebot ansetzen muss dass
man gezielte Wirtschaftshilfen machen
muss weil eben wir hatten vorher schon
vor diesem Angriff der Ukraine die
höchsten Energiepreise in Europa und
fast weltweit das heißt es war schon da
absehbar dass das schwierig wird und
dass wir in ein Mangel reingehen Mangel
ist noch mal eine Verschärfung der
Problematik das heißt diese Monate war
und da hat man über Gerechtigkeit ist
jetzt das Gericht dass der eine was
kriegt und der andere das sind nicht die
entscheidenden Fragen wenn man hier
wahrscheinlich schon vorher nicht was
denken Sie was was sind die
entscheidenden Fragen für Wählerinnen
und Wähler im Osten die ja jetzt sehr
stark auch wieder die AFD unterstützen
also wenn man in Sachsen und Thüringen
würden die jeweils die stärkste Kraft
werden also was was sind denn da dann
die Hauptthemen also die AFD hat da nie
verloren die AFD ist einfach konstant
stark die Gefahr besteht jetzt sogar
dass sie über ihr bisheriges Klientel
hinaus über relativ aus mobilisiert noch
mehr Prozentpunkte hinzugewinnt und ich
habe das vorhin schon mal anklingen
lassen sie wissen ja alle dass sozusagen
der Aufbau nicht nur der Demokratie
sondern auch der Wirtschaft in
Ostdeutschland nach 1990 einfach
verdammt kompliziert war das ist anders
als in Westdeutschland
kein kein goldenen Aufschwung gab
finanziert unter anderem von den USA
sondern dass man dass man da richtig zu
kämpfen hatte wir hatten lange Phasen
von Arbeitslosigkeit bei von
Arbeitslosigkeit von um die 30 Prozent
in verschiedenen Regionen so jetzt ist
es in den zurückliegenden zehn Jahren
schon gelungen einen kleinen Wohlstand
aufzubauen ist etwas was manchmal ein
bisschen untergeht in der Debatte über
Ostdeutschland und den zu verlieren da
Frau graut es natürlich vielen aber
diese Wohlstand nicht besonders groß ist
aber auch B weil der Prozentsatz derer
die beispielsweise in Ostdeutschland
Mindestlohn verdienen nur Mindestlohn
und nicht viel mehr einfach sehr viel
höher ist als in Westdeutschland jetzt
steigt aber dieser dann könnte man doch
erwarten davon profitieren die
Ostdeutschen sehr ja also viele in
Ostdeutschland aber
dann auf andere Ebene noch mal dass
diese ganzen entlastungspakete trotzdem
immer den Anschein erwecken dass es viel
zu wenig ist auf allen Ebenen darüber
reden wir schon den ganzen Abend sie
haben eben auch gesagt Mindestlohn
gleich jetzt die Inflation im Prinzip
aus und tragt sie vielleicht
gleichzeitig noch an also auch das ist
ich will jetzt hier gar nicht der große
regierungsversteher sein aber auch das
ist natürlich etwas dass man einerseits
kommunikativ den Anschein erweckt you
never walk alone und man es versteht
oder nicht wir lassen hier niemand
zurück aber wir wissen das eigentlich
nicht genau ob das wirklich gelingt also
das finde ich kommunikativ wirklich eine
Herausforderung zu sagen wir tun unser
Bestes aber wir können ehrlicherweise
trotzdem nicht garantieren wie der
Winter aussehen wird und das ist doch
sehr sehr hart wird für manche und auch
dieser Mindestlohn sicherlich eine große
Errungenschaft aber die Leute werden am
Ende trotzdem denken das Geld reicht
einfach nicht ne und das finde ich ist
noch mal so ein Punkt wo man merkt dass
es sind einfach
extreme Zeiten aber das Versprechen dass
man niemand allein lässt es war ja so
ein bisschen verstanden worden und so
ist auch die Erwartung der Bevölkerung
dass jedem dieser Härte abgenommen wird
und das geht schlichtweg nicht weil
diese Steigerung die kommen
externer nach Deutschland getragener
angebotsschock das heißt wir haben als
Land ein mächtigen Wohlstandsverlust und
den kann man nicht
staatlicherseits Weg
ja entlasten sondern man entlastet im
Moment auf Pump das heißt der Verlust
ist trotzdem da und wir
versuchen aber
uns davor zu mogeln irgendwie dass man
es nicht so merkt das kommt geballt auf
uns zurück weil diese Schulen alles und
ja aber nochmal ist wenn es
inflationstreiben geht ist das ein
Problem wenn wir innerhalb alles was wir
machen jetzt an schuldenprogramm machen
die anderen Länder auch in Südeuropa
guckt man sehr genau was wir jetzt im
Moment machen das machen die natürlich
auch alle in unserem Währungsraum also
deswegen muss man natürlich schon diese
Ehrlichkeit und dann auch eine gewisse
Härte eigentlich erwarten damit man
nicht sagt es geht nicht nur um zwei
Jahre es geht diese Preise diese
Energiepreise werden niemals wieder auf
das Niveau von vorletzten
Winter ist vollkommen klar der nächste
Winter gesagt jetzt wenn jetzt nichts
passiert dann ist der wirtschaftsstand
aber deswegen muss man das Geld doch
trotzdem gezielt und nicht sagen wir
machen alle in der Bevölkerung und dann
haben wir wieder ein bisschen irgendwie
oder ist doch das Problem
macht also dass man eben nicht alle
Rentner beglückt dass man nicht alle
Arbeitnehmer
hier sagt wir machen auch eine
Fortsetzung des 9 Euro Tickets zwar ein
bisschen teurer aber eben trotzdem das
sind alles wahnsinnige Ausgaben die sind
im Moment nicht prioritär wir müssten
Prioritäten setzen um nicht
staatlicherseits diese Inflation nach
oben an zu immer glauben Sie mal was wir
noch für eine soziale Krise haben wenn
die Inflation nächstes Jahr noch höher
als wir sind dann müsste oder müsste man
müsste man vielleicht ehrlicher machen
dass der Staat eben nicht für alles
sorgen kann und dass wir dann eben dass
dieser Wohlstandsverlust eben ja auch
viele treffen wird ja selbstverständlich
also da bin ich ganz bei der Kollegin
natürlich muss man
Studenten die
arm sind und kaum über die Runden kommen
staatlicherseits unterstützen das
gleiche gilt Rentner und das gilt für
Geringverdiener aber mittlere Einkommen
muss man tatsächlich nicht in der Breite
als Staat irgendwie über diesen Winter
schleppen da muss man tatsächlich sagen
dass also da ist einfach der das was
jetzt hier als Angebot schockt das Land
sozusagen überrollt hat einfach zu
gewaltig als sind wir das alles
auffangen können sondern da muss man
auch ganz ehrlich sagen und da war
Habeck finde ich der bessere
Kommunikator als Scholz der das alles so
ein bisschen weich spült wir werden
gewaltige Wohlstandsverluste auf breiter
Front erleben und das wird sie alle
erwischen so das meine ich mit guter
Kommunikation
auf schaut wen sollte man entlasten ist
das ein Punkt wo sie sagen da muss ich
die Ampel jetzt dran dran messen lassen
dass sie das dann irgendwann mal
zielgerichteter macht ja daran muss sie
sich messen lassen vor allem ist ja für
uns alle relevant wie diese
gaspreisbremse die in der Diskussion ist
jetzt aussehen wird also wir reden seit
Wochen darüber bisschen auffällig ist
dass es noch keine konkrete Idee gibt
wie diese gaspreisbremse umgesetzt
werden soll also es wurde ausgelagert in
eine Kommission diese Entscheidung ist
etwas was wir kennen von Angela Merkel
das war für ihre Regierungszeit ja
üblich Kommission zu bilden für
strittige Fragen hat auch den positiven
Nebeneffekt für die Regierung dass man
dann hinterher nicht so sehr dafür
verantwortlich gemacht wird nun müssen
wir mal gucken was diese Kommission die
gar nicht allzu viel Zeit hatte um zu
Tagen was diese Kommission präsentieren
wird denn die Aufgabe ist ja total
schwierig sie haben es gesagt es geht um
den Winter der jetzt bevorsteht das darf
keine komplizierte Lösung sein sie muss
einfach umsetzbar sein wenn man
zielgenau machen will wird es oft
kompliziert
es wird sozusagen die breite Masse wird
davon profitieren und die Frage ist wie
man es überhaupt organisieren kann damit
es schnell umsetzbar ist damit man keine
Software schreiben muss die drei Monate
braucht also da sind wir gespannt wird
auf einen anderen Punkt gerne kommen
Herr fast wenn man jetzt sagt das ist so
eine ja eine gigantische Krise und
solche riesenaufgaben ist es ja auch
eine Zeit eigentlich für eine
Opposition besonders konstruktiv zu sein
da das haben wir am Anfang bei Corona
auch erlebt dass alle da zusammen waren
wie füllt denn die CDU und vor allen
Dingen auch der Oppositionsführer märz
im Moment diese konstruktive Rolle aus
sie hatten ja eben nach Personen gefragt
und sehr interessant wenn man sich so
Top Ten Rankings anguckt dann sind der
Regierungspolitiker in die die da oben
stehen
wer war grabeck Scholz die sind
eigentlich die drei die da oben stehen
also ein bisschen Vertrauen scheinen sie
dann schon zu genießen umgekehrt Söder
März tatsächlich diejenigen die immer
noch im Durchschnitt negativ bewertet
werden also das verfängt irgendwie nicht
und es hat ja eben nicht nur diese
kommunikative Ebene sondern wir haben ja
auch gerade
Ministerpräsident in Konferenzen
Zusammenkünfte mit dem Kanzler erlebt
also dass da über die Ebenen und da
kommen so zwei Logiken zusammen Bund
Land Partei so richtig Krise scheint man
da auch noch nicht verstanden zu haben
weil sonst hätte man auf allen Seiten
glaube ich dieses nicht beschließen auf
der letzten Runde sich eigentlich nicht
leisten können also da merkt man schon
dass doch noch einiges
aber
das
die die dass wir man sieht einfach sehr
sehr viel Polarisierung Umfragen gerade
und das heißt dann letztlich schon dass
da so ein an einem Strang ziehen sicher
nicht das dominante Motiv für die
Opposition gerade ist aber bei der
Opposition also ganz so würde ich es
nicht stehen lassen wollen ich fand das
die Union also vor allen Dingen auch
märz als es um die Unterstützung der
Ukraine ging auch mit Waffen derjenige
war der die Regierung getrieben hat weil
Scholz wollte eigentlich am Anfang nicht
und jetzt hier den die gasumlage hat die
Union ganz klar gesagt sie geht da
notfalls vor Gericht das ist nicht das
war ja auch wohl nicht rechts also
rechtliche korrekt was da gemacht
zusammengeschustert wurde zeigt sich
eben das im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium wohl auch
an leitender Stelle keine Juristen mehr
sitzen das ist sind natürlich schon
Punkte ich denke für die Union
unabhängig davon ob März jetzt ein
Sympathieträger ist oder nicht was er
eben für für weite Teile eben noch nie
war ich denke tatsächlich dass die
Wirtschaftskrise im absolut in die Hand
spielen wird und eben auch die Tatsache
dass die FDP eben für diese Themen wie
Inflation ob sie dafür was kann oder
nicht also für ein Haushalt wofür sie
auf alle Fälle was kann weil da hast du
den Minister
eben dass sie da Federn lassen wird und
das wird die Union im Zweifelsfall
einsammeln können und ich denke auch
sein Kurs der hier auch schon kritisiert
worden ist mit
dass er den also ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen zum Teil sozial Tourismus
vorgeworfen hat ist dann zurückgerudert
aber er hat natürlich auch mit diesem
sich mal wir sind was die
Flüchtlingszahlen angehen weiter als
2015 auch dieses Thema ist die Frage wer
sammelt da ein die Union oder die die
AFD aber bleiben wir nochmal bei der
Union wie würden sie es denn beurteilen
wie sehen sie die Rolle der Union gerade
im Moment oder welche Chance hätte sie
noch vielleicht um ja in diesen Krisen
auch mit zu unterstützen vielleicht noch
eine kleine Korrektur wenn ich darf ich
halte jetzt von allen politischen
Umfragen diese Beliebtheit zu Rankings
einzelner Politiker wirklich für die
wenigsten am wenigsten rel werden aber
wieso wie sie es referiert haben stimmt
es glaube ich nicht mehr ich glaube
Söder ist mittlerweile an der an der
Spitze als
unions Politiker und Herr Habeck ist
doch relativ weit abgerutscht in dem
Fall eine Insel Umfrage für die
Bildzeitung Politbarometer hat die
Reihenfolge gegründet methodisch nicht
sauber Bericht nein aber das sozusagen
in langer Sicht ähm
sie können es ja mal angucken wie das
Politbarometer sozusagen im letzten
Monat sich entwickelt hat ist es sehr
sehr stabil und was die was die was die
was Herrn März angeht da würde ich das
vielleicht ein bisschen anders bewerten
als die Kollegin ich fand dieses diesen
Begriff des sozialtourismus den er da
verwendet hat tatsächlich absolut
unterirdisch es gibt also keine Daten
die jetzt irgendwie ein
Sozialbetrug im größeren Ausmaß
irgendwie belegen würden und es geht
hier um eine Million Menschen in
Deutschland die vor einem Krieg geflohen
sind denken Sie warum hat er es
verwendet naja ich meine das war war
sicherlich kein Unfall der Mann ist 66
Jahre alt sein halbes Leben in der
Politik das ist ein Profi er redet mit
dem größten Boulevard Medium des Landes
der hat diesen Begriff ganz bewusst
gesetzt er wurde auch nicht danach
gefragt er hat das selbst sozusagen
wollte das als als talkingpoint
unterbringen und dann ist er
zurückgerudert natürlich kann man muss
muss man über das Thema reden dass ganz
viele Bundesländer was die Kapazitäten
für die Unterbringung von Versorgung von
Flüchtlingen angeht an ihrer Grenze sind
die meisten Bundesländer nehmen keine
Flüchtlinge mehr auf natürlich hat
Deutschland ein ganz grundsätzliches
Problem mit ihr regulärer Migration mit
ganz vielen Menschen die keinen Asyl
nächste Woche wenn es den
flüchtlingsgipfel gibt nur drei Minuten
haben also kann die Opposition sozusagen
die diese Krisenbewältigung der
Ampelkoalition unterstützen sollte sie
sie überhaupt unterstützen oder in
solche großen Krise
ja sie sollte die politischen Vorschläge
unterstützen die sinnvoll sind und
andernfalls als als kräftige Opposition
möglichst laut widersprechen würde ich
sagen also das geht hier nicht irgendwie
man muss jetzt nicht jede gigantische
neue Ausgabe irgendwie als Opposition
mittragen
freue mich welche Chancen hat die CDU
auch um im Osten weiter ja wer dazu
finden ich glaube dass es ihr sehr gut
getan hat in die Opposition zu geraten
also heute vor einem Jahr aus der
Regierung herausgewählt zu werden es war
wahrscheinlich aus Sicht der CDU das
Beste was ihr passieren konnte weil sie
sich so jetzt neu organisieren kann weil
sie in Zeiten die so schweren Krise am
Rand stehen und gute Ratschläge geben
kann das ist ja nun mal die Aufgabe von
Oppositionen das soll auch so sein und
das gilt jetzt nicht für den ganzen
Osten aber beispielsweise Sachsen und
Thüringen sind einfach relativ
konservative Gegenden und hier gibt es
ein großes Potenzial und ich denke die
CDU aber gut damit beraten genau
zuzuhören was die Leute denken oder sie
vom Gegenteil zu überzeugen da hat sie
so ein bisschen ein
Kommunikationsproblem weil Michael
Kretschmer ganz anders spricht als der
Parteivorsitzende wenn es um die Ukraine
Politik geht das ist auch okay in einer
in einer Volkspartei aber er ist ist
natürlich ein etwas widersprüchlichen
Eindruck er Fass wird diese
ampelkollektion halten bis zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode also zumindest noch
eine ganze Weile weil glaube ich allen
drei Parteien auch klar ist derjenige
der das Bündnis zum platzen bringen
würde der würde dafür wirklich brutal
abgestraft das wäre auch nicht
vermittelbar an dieser Zeit insofern
Sonntag ist ja Wahl Niedersachsen das
könnte für einige der ampelparteien die
FDP zum Beispiel wirklich ein heikler
Moment werden unter fünf Prozent käme
das heißt also du könntest das wäre für
die FDP ja ein echtes Problem aber
zugleich kann sie auch nicht dieses
profilieren weiter auf die Spitze
treiben ich meine die Kontroversen sind
schon so groß darüber sprechen wir den
ganzen Abend dass die Ampel nicht
funktioniert das zeigt auch noch mal was
das wirklich bedeutet für diese Ampel
sie müssen sich profilieren als Parteien
aber Sie müssen auch als Bündnis
funktionieren und das passt eben
vielleicht weniger als bei früheren
Bündnissen zusammen dann ganz kurz von
Ihnen beiden hat die Einschätzung hält
die Ampel also alle drei Parteien stehen
ja schlechter da als bei der
Bundestagswahl also alle und deshalb
glaube ich ist der Außenpolitik
taktischen Gründen wird es keiner machen
ob es für das Land heilsam das wird wird
sich zeigen wenn dieser Winter erstmal
durch ist was den genannten Gründen wird
die Koalition behalten würde ich auch
sagen und würden sie auch sagen vorhin
ja
gut dann gehen wir mal davon aus dass
sie hält über die ganze Frage wie man
wenn wir mit den Flüchtlingen umgehen
sprechen wir nächste Woche in der
Phoenix Runde aber am Sonntag sprechen
wir natürlich erstmal über die Wahl in
Niedersachsen dann ab nach der
Tagesschau bei Phoenix gibt es dann die
Diskussion über die Auswirkungen auf die
Bundespolitik der Wahl in Niedersachsen
schön dass Sie dabei waren bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]